[Music]
here we go again happy new year Sony
have revealed the free games for PS Plus
subscribers for the month of January
2020 we'll be able to get our grubby
hands on these from Tuesday the 7th of
January do me a favor
like and subscribe if you enjoy these
videos and let's get straight into it
the first game is a PlayStation behemoth
this is uncharted the Nathan Drake
collection the iconic third-person
action shooter the entire original
trilogy all three games lovingly
remastered and upgraded to look and feel
great on ps4 the first Uncharted game
titled drake's Fortune released on the
ps3 back in 2007 how old does that make
you feel well now with a buff to the
framerate at 60 frames per second it
doesn't suffer from the slow down and
bogged down feel of many games which
move from one console generation to
another the second game is my personal
favorite the story is riveting the
explosive set pieces will blow your mind
and the characters really come to life
in that one if you don't plan on playing
all three games
I recommend going straight to this one
the third game drake's Deception doubled
down on everything they've learned up to
this point arguably perfecting the
mechanics of cover shooting and
balls-to-the-wall action adventure if
you're new to the series this edition
will last you weeks if not months and if
you know the series well jump back in to
see how things have improved reviews are
through the roof on this one between
eight and ten seem to be the average and
all I can think about is going back in
to relive that train car falling from
the cliff that was one of the best
moments in videogame history the next
game is a simulation game but it's not
really it's a comedy completely a comedy
back in 2014 goat simulator came out
yeah you've heard me right we're taking
control of a goat this month and
wreaking havoc on this town in essence
the game is about exploration and
ragdoll physics I mean getting run over
is satisfying in all the wrong ways it
appears the aim of the game is to build
up a multiplayer based on your carnage
around the town but realistically it's
about doing the most ridiculous things
you can imagine there are collectibles
there are Easter eggs there are tough
physics based challenges to beat to
finding the hidden jetpack will change
your goal
forever the critics absolutely hate this
game with a passion giving it as low as
three out of ten but some actually love
it
including IGN which goes to prove one
thing review scores are completely
meaningless try this out and see what
you think of it it won't last you a long
time but it will give you a few giggles
so there we have it what do you think of
the first games of 2020 technically
there's four games here let me know your
thoughts I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade
all the best for 2020
[Music]